字幕: Moe Serizawa
校正: Koichiro Yoda
まず この写真を
見ていただきたいんですけどね
この画像 見覚えありますでしょうか？
これは この８月
日本の若い女性がソウルに行かれて
そのときに 韓国の多分若い男性に
まあ いわゆるナンパをされて
そのナンパをされたのを
無視して歩いていたら
追っかけられて髪の毛を引っ張られて
引きずり倒されるみたいな
暴行を受けたっていうお話です
これは 実は動画だったので
テレビにも馴染む
テレビでもたくさん バラエティと
ニュースバラエティなんかでも報道されて
YouTubeなんかでも
たくさん上がってたと思います
だから 見た方 多いんじゃないでしょうか？
実は この事件が起きた日の夜に
僕は ソウルの空港に到着したんです
それは 日本と韓国との間で
国際学会がありまして
私は それに出席する必要が
あったからここに着いた
で 空港に降り立って
スマホの電源を入れると
私のLINEとか メールとかに
私の友人 知人から沢山ですね
「こんなときに韓国行って大丈夫か？」
それから
「お前 少なくとも日本語は話すなよ」とか
最悪なのは「生きて帰ってこいよ」とか
（笑）
そういうね 脅しのような
僕はまだこれが起こったことを
分かっていないので
一体なんなんだろう？と思ってですね
まぁ ちょっと驚きながらもですね
スマホをポケットにしまって
一回ホテルに着きました
ホテルに着いて
どうもこういうことがあったらしいってのは
ちょっと調べたんですけど
その日の夜には
韓国の学会が主催している
懇親会があったので
私は そこに行かなければいけなかった
懇親会に行くのに地図を片手に
ソウルの街をウロウロと歩いていたら
案の定 道に迷ったんです
私は道に迷うと
基本的に人に聞くタイプの人間なので
私は 残念なことにコリア語ができません
だから まあ カタコトの英語で
分かりそうな人っていうのを
キョロキョロと探しながら歩いたんですが
そうしたら ちょうど前からですね
お巡りさんがやって来た
お巡りさんだったら まあ
英語も出来るだろうし
道もよく知ってるだろうと思って
僕はですね 片言の英語で
自分が行きたいレストラン
どこにありますか？と聞いたんです
するとですね
そのお巡りさんは
「日本の方ですか？」って
日本語で聞いたんです
僕は ドキッ！としましてね
いやぁ これはちょっと
もし なんか難癖つけられて
不当逮捕とかされたら
韓国に知ってる弁護士も
いないしなって一瞬思ったんです
で だから 僕は
”No, no. I’m from China.“って
言おうかなと思ったんですが
まあ 流石にここは腹を決めて
「そうです」
日本語で返事をしました
すると そのお巡りさんは
ニコッと微笑まれる
「ようこそ 韓国へ」って言って
非常に丁寧に 日本語で
僕が行こうと思っていた
レストランを教えてくれました
つまり
ここで起こったことはですね
日本のメディアによる情報
ニュースを見ていた僕の友人たちは
いわゆる反日ムードが非常に高まっている
「大変なときに君は行ってるね」って
心配してくれたわけです
ところが 実際に韓国に行った私は
お巡りさんにとても親切にしてもらって
そして 全然 反日ムードなんていうのは
感じなかったんですね
つまり 大きなギャップがあったわけです
メディアが伝える現実と本当の現実
で このギャップは
どうして生じたのかっていうと
これをちょっと 料理をたとえ話に
お話をしたいと思います
みなさんは 中華料理がお好きだと思います
日本人が大好きな料理ベスト３とかに
入ってるらしいですけど
で この中華料理屋さんに行くと
ある統計だと３人に２人は
頼むものが餃子だそうなんですよ
この餃子って つまり中国の料理ですから
餃子ってのは中国にも
もちろんあるんですけども
中国に行かれた方は分かると思いますが
中国で「餃子」って注文すると
焼いてないんですよ
茹でてある 茹でた餃子が出る
つまり 日本で言うところの
水餃子っていうものが出てきます
基本的に
焼き餃子っていうのは 無い店の方が多いです
この餃子というものがですね
ようするに同じ名前です 当然ね
日本でも中国でも餃子と言いますけれども
同じ名前で 基本的には同じ食材を
使っているんですけども
料理法や味付けが違う
なんでこういうことが起こるのかというと
言うまでもないことなんですけれども
もともと発祥は中国ですから
それを日本に導入するときに
日本のいわゆる料理人の方が
日本人の口に合うように
調理をして 味付けをして
提供しているわけですよね
実は このことは
ニュースの世界でも全く同じことが起こります
つまり 我々が普段
中国のニュース
中国で今日 こういうことがあったとかですね
そういった中国のニュースっていうのを
見たり 聞いたり 読んだり
しているものというのは
実は 日本のジャーナリストー
記者の方がですね
色んなニュースの素材がある中で
「これは日本人の口に合うだろう」
と言って選んで
しかも それを我々日本人が面白いように
分かりやすいように
味付けをして ようするに
みなさんの所に提供しているわけです
ですから 我々が中国の情報
中国のニュースというものを
日本のメディアから
入手しているものというのは
必ずしも中国の本場の
つまり 現地の中国のメディアが
報じているものと同じとは限らないわけです
ここで何の問題が起きるのかと言うとですね
先ほどの餃子の例をとってお話をすると
たとえば お互いの国の
餃子事情について
全然知らない日本人と中国人が
餃子談義を始めたと考えてみてください
つまり
餃子っていうのは
どんなお酒に合うのかとか
どこのお店の餃子が美味しいかとか
餃子の真髄とは何かとか
つまり そんなようなお話なんですけども
そうすると 中国の方は
「やっぱり餃子は茹で加減だよね」
「はあ？」
「いや やっぱりあの店の餃子は
焼き加減が上手だから
あの店はやっぱり最高だよね」
「はあ？」って話になります
つまりこれは
同じ餃子というものを
議論しようとしているんだけども
お互いの国にですね
その餃子というものが
異なった味付けで伝わっているために
議論の土台が同じになっていない
ということになります
これは 今 餃子の話だから
笑い話で済むんですけれども
これが政治とか経済の
ニュースとなると
ちょっと大きな問題
国際問題が起こることがあります
最近の例で
こういった問題が
表に出た話を１つしましょう
先ほどもちょっと言いましたけど
今 戦後最悪の日韓関係と
言われている状況の中で
みなさんは
戦後最悪の日韓関係を
ある意味演出した物の
１つのニュースに
「盗人猛々しい」発言って覚えてますか？
これは 韓国の文大統領という方が
発言したというふうに
日本では伝えられたものなんです
これは 一体どういう文脈で
この発言を彼がなさったかというと
日本が韓国をいわゆる貿易上の手続きの
優遇国から外すということを発表した
それを受けて 韓国の文大統領が記者会見で
「盗人猛々しい」というふうに
発言したと日本では伝わりました
この発言を受けて
日本の一部の政治家とか
いわゆる評論家とか
ニュースバラエティに出てくるような
ゲストの人とかの中からは
「無礼だ」とか「失礼だ」とか
「大統領が口にするとは
思えないような品の悪い言葉だ」とか
「韓国人の品格を疑う」というような
リアクションが出たのは
覚えておられると思います
ところがですね
実は この文大統領が本当に口にされた
言葉というのがここにありますけれども
この「賊反荷杖（チョクパンハジャン）」
と言うんだそうです
私 コリア語ができないので
発音があやふやなんですけれども
意味は「盗人猛々しい」で
基本的には間違ってないそうです
ところが よく見ていただくと
これは 漢字四字熟語ですよね
漢字四字熟語っていうのは
日本でも同じですけれども
たとえば 驚天動地というのと同じように
基本的にはインテリの人が
口にするような
品のいい言葉なんです
韓国では比較的これはよく使われてる
言葉だそうなんですけど
いずれにしても
日本語の「盗人猛々しい」とは
随分ニュアンスの違う言葉です
これは しかも さらに悪いことに
韓国のKBSなんかのメディアが
日本のメディアとか一般の世論が
我が韓国の大統領の
「賊反荷杖」という言葉が
下品だとかなんとかっていうような
報道をしているっていうことが
伝わっちゃったんですよね
でも この「賊反荷杖」っていうのを
「盗人猛々しい」と訳したと
彼らは知らないんですよ
ようするに 餃子なら餃子と
同じ餃子だと思ってるんです
「賊反荷杖のどこが悪いんだ？」って
ようするに 先ほどの餃子の話と全く同じで
この「賊反荷杖」って話は
日本での伝えられ方というのは
結局 日本風に味付けをされたわけです
当時のメディアー
私の知る限りは 大手では毎日新聞以外は
みんなこれを盗人猛々しいと
訳したんです NHKも含めですね
当時の日韓の戦後最悪のっていう状況に鑑み
さらに 盗人猛々しいって
訳した方が分かりやすいし
たぶん ウケるだろうというような意味で
おそらく そういうふうな
訳をつけたと思うんですけども
これがやはり 日本と韓国の間の
お互いの国民感情というか
それをもう損ねたことは
言うまでもないと思います
さて 実はこのように
外国の情報を自分の国の
国民の口に合うような形で
調理して味付けをして
もちろん 選択もなんですけども
そうやって伝えるというのは決してですね
日本だけの問題
日本のジャーナリズムだけの
問題ではありません
これは 実はもう 世界中どこの国でも
基本的には同じようなことをやっています
世界中の国で同じようなことを
やっているということは
世界中の国でさっき言ったような
日韓関係のような
賊反荷杖みたいな問題が
起こりうるということを意味しています
これは いわゆる国際報道の世界では
長らく大きな問題というふうに
されていたんですけれども
この問題を解決する方法は
ないのかっていうと
実はですね
これは １つヒントが
ヨーロッパにあります
これはヨーロッパに
私が10年以上前にお邪魔したときに
自分で撮ってきた写真なんですけども
“EuroNews”という
放送局というかジャーナリズム
ニュース専門の放送局があります
もちろん インターネットでも
流していますので
みなさんアクセスされれば
見ることができますが
このEuroNewsというのは
フランスのリヨンにありますが
ただし ヨーロッパ中の
公共放送を中心とした
ジャーナリストを集め
公共放送から基本的には
お金を集めて
運営されているものです
このEuroNewsの特徴の１つは
「ヨーロッパの料理」を
届けているということです
基本的には ドイツの放送局というのは
ドイツ風に味付けをした
フランスの話とか
イギリスの話とかを
しているわけですけれども
ところが
このEuroNewsは
ヨーロッパ料理というものを作っている
つまりヨーロッパの味付けで
ヨーロッパの視点から見た選択をして
ニュースの選択ですね
そして それをヨーロッパの国々に
あまねく伝えるということをやっています
そして 今 この写真が出ていますけれども
２つ目の特徴に
このEuroNewsのすごいところは
現在 ヨーロッパの12の言語で
放送しているんです
今この写真というのは
１つ１つが言語別のジャーナリストが
入るブースになってるんです
こっち側にいわゆるプロジェクターというか
スクリーンがありまして
たとえば ライブ中継なんかを
放送するときに
その同じ画面を見ながら
異なる言語で伝えていく
ということは
そのEuroNewsを見ている方は
自分が慣れ親しんだ自分の言語で
同じヨーロッパ中の人が
同じ情報を聞いたり 見たり
読んだりすることが
できているということです
それは 言うまでもないことですが
先ほどの餃子の話ではありませんが
みんなの共通理解が可能になるわけです
つまり 同じニュースを
消費しているわけです
こういったことが
当然のことながら
ヨーロッパの中での
国際理解を深め
そして 現在のヨーロッパ統合に
一役買っていることは
もう言うまでもありません
さて ここで最後に
みなさんにご提案があります
みなさんは「同じ釜の飯を食った仲間」
っていう言葉をご存知でしょ？
つまり 私が提案したいのは
同じアジア料理というー
アジアの視点で選ばれた
ニュースのことですが
アジア料理というものを
アジアの人たちみんなが
同じものを食べる
消費するということで
今よりも もう少し
仲良くなれるんじゃないでしょうか
これは
つまり
同じ政治的な問題でも
経済的な問題でも
なんでもいいんですけれども
それを話し合うときの土壌として
同じニュース 同じ情報をもとに
議論をするということを意味しています
ぜひ みなさんに考えていただきたいのは
これを先ほどのEuroNewsに倣えば
できれば 日本には日本語で
韓国にはコリア語で
中国にはチャイニーズでという形で
ようするに 同じ情報を異なる言語で
つまり それぞれの国の
食べやすい形で提供することで
みんなが同じ情報という土台でもって
アジアの問題を議論することが
できるんじゃないでしょうか
最後に この中にいる
今日は 日本人の方がほとんど
オーディエンスだと思いますけれど
アジアの方も見ていただけると
思っていますので
お話をしたいんですがね
これまで述べてきたように
ようするに
自分の国のメディアが伝える
外国のニュースだけを信じて
それを毎日読んだり見たり
聞いたりしているだけでは
真の国際理解はできません
ぜひですね
このアジア共通のニュースの
必要性っていうものを
みなさん お考えになっていただいて
それが必要だなと思ったら
それぞれの国の中で声を上げていただいて
公共放送に働きかけるでも
お金持ちの人に働きかけるでも
なんでもいいんですけれども
そういう形でこういった
EuroNewsのアジア版
みたいなものを作って
みんなで同じアジア料理を食べて
アジアの問題を議論できるような場にしたい
そういう日が１日も早く来ることを
私は祈っています
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）